this week on prod Rica Germany land of
opportunity newly released data shows
Germany is now the second most popular
destination for migrants overtaking
traditional immigration countries like
Canada and Australia hundreds of
thousands of people are moving to
Germany every year most of them in
search of work and a brighter future but
not everyone is welcome in Europe's new
land of opportunity asylum seekers often
face an uphill battles legal hurdles
make it difficult for many to settle in
Germany some migrants have even endured
violence from far-right groups who want
them out so what's causing the current
boom in migration is Germany truly ready
to welcome the thousands who want to
call it home your host this week is Ali
Osman hello and welcome to quadriga this
show is being broadcast worldwide and if
I were to ask our viewers out there
where would you like to live the
question more and more seems to be
Germany why is that the case why is
Germany the second most popular country
for immigrants worldwide what are the
reasons that's what I want to talk on
today's show together with these three
experts
welcome to Alan Posner who is a
british-born correspondent and
commentator for the German daily
newspaper debate he's also one of
Germany's most prominent bloggers as
well as the author of numerous books
catagen asto Klose
is a professor at the University of
Southern Denmark she's of Polish origin
and previously had at the Central and
Eastern Europe Department at the German
Council on Foreign Relations
and Pascal ug is the Germany
correspondent for the French weekly news
magazine Labuan she's also columnist for
the German newspapers the attackers
villain in zoo culture as well as the
author of several books
welcome to you all on today's show Allan
Poe Xena what's up with that Germany the
second most popular country for
immigrants worldwide only after the
United States but before very typical
and historic immigrant countries like
Canada and Australia the numbers don't
lie
in 2002 400,000 people came to Germany
that's an increase by almost 40%
compared to 2011 what do you think what
other reasons well you know you have to
say first of all the reason isn't really
the Germany such a great place though I
love it
it's the the rest of Europe is such an
awful place to find work and you know
and and people are coming here from
Spain they're coming here from Greece
they're coming here from Italy they're
coming from Poland they're coming from
Romania Bulgaria and so on because they
need to find a place to work and Europe
Germany is sort of an island within
Europe where we have low unemployment
and and people are actually crying out
to find workers so we are profiting in a
way if you think that immigration is a
good thing and I do we're profiting from
the bad situation in the rest of Europe
to be quite frank and then also of
course from crisis things like in Syria
and so on so it's the economy stupid as
Bill Clinton once said that's of course
one reason which we will get to the
bottom of more closely about Pascal
youth if we look at the numbers in 2009
Germany was only the eighth largest
country as far as immigration is
concerned now it is the second that's a
jump from 8 to 2 in a time span of only
five years now the the euro crisis
obviously and the financial crisis has
been mentioned could that be the only
reason though I think it's the the main
reason I agree with you it's the main
reason I mean all other countries are in
Christ is my country's a in a very deep
economic crisis and after the election
the European election on last Sunday
well if I was black if I was Syrian if I
was Muslim I wouldn't like to try and
knock at the door of France I mean it's
it's maybe dangerous at the best and at
the worst it's dangerous at the best
you're not welcome
and there's no jobs I mean in France the
it's you we have twice as much are
bicycles each kind employed unemployed
as in Germany it's very very very
difficult for young people most young
people under 35 I mean the people who
voted in the for Nationale the right
extremist party in France there are very
very many young people because one-third
of the youngster young people come out
of university or who have done a who've
learned a job don't find employment and
that's terrible and who wants to
emigrate in in a place like that so I
think Germany's the better from from the
lot and that's why people come here in
Cartagena stock was a indeed the economy
is very strong in Germany very solid
particularly compared to its European
neighbours unemployment is low but
before we get perhaps more into why the
people are coming let's see who's coming
who are these people coming to Germany
where are they from primarily it's very
interesting because this has changed a
lot and when we compare the situation
now migration in in Germany and ten
years ago and migration in the 60s above
all that qualified people came from
southern Europe in that time from Italy
and now we have very well qualified
migration the best people from all
around the world from southern Europe
from central Eastern Europe and above
all people with great qualification
arrived Germany and this is a new trend
it's a new trend in comparison to
nineteen sixties but even in comparison
ten years ago so now we can say that
Germany profits from the migration
outside Germany from diverse European
countries so I'll impose them mostly
from Central and Eastern Europe then
that seems to be the case and indeed
Germany has demographic challenges out
there it's a rapidly aging society with
a relatively low
birth rate so these labor and the
skilled labor force is very much welcome
isn't it
absolutely I mean we're there are also I
mean from teachers down to qualified
machine operators we have huge
opportunities and a need for immigration
and as katrina says i mean it's great
not to have sort of the immigration we
had just five ten years ago to people
coming here just for benefits you know
benefit tourism as it was called but
really coming here to work and they have
the qualifications and we have to say
one very important thing after the last
european elections that this is because
of the EU because people still aren't
coming shall we say from india or for
other high-tech country the
qualifications they're still going to
the US and canada canada but they are
coming from Italy from as you say from
Poland and so on so this is thanks to
the EU thanks to Schengen thanks to the
the ability of any European citizen to
settle wherever they want which is why
the four nacionales are
counter-productive and as far as Frances
future is concerned because we all need
this so thanks to the EU almost more
than to Germany no thanks to the you is
what you say but do you think that's
also the the sentiment across the
country particularly among its political
elite well definitely among the
political elite and among the economic
elite and if you in the last elections
the AFD which even they aren't really
anti-immigrant but yeah the alternative
of pradosham which ones Germany to leave
the euro but not the European Union even
they are for for immigration so I think
there's a broad consensus and were and
and our president said that we we would
we want a new new German we of diversity
and that's something quite new in German
discussion I disagree because you're
talking of qualified qualified
immigration now I'm not quite sure I
think it's the the ground feeling is the
same here as it is in France I'm if you
are unqualified if you come from Africa
on the boat
I mean you if you come from Syria then
it's
much more difficult to get you know to
then I don't think that would the German
welcome you as much as a doctor from
Poland or a qualified engineer I was as
India from India and we've seen in the
last years how Europe has closed these
doors and tried to and and promoted new
legislation so that you have to when you
arrive from outside you have to stay in
the country where you arrive and these
are all the countries like Italy
Portugal I mean the countries which are
on the Mediterranean Germany's in the
middle it's very very protected and the
Germans are the ones who don't want to
change this law because they know it's
difficult to get to Germany I mean they
protect themselves very much to think in
first well qualified immigrants
I think Drummond has learned a lot from
other countries from neighbor countries
above all from northern European
countries not only European countries
neitherlands and dana mark is a very
very well developed perfect migration
system and Germany has learned a lot
because was different ten years ago
the other point I'm agree with you
completely agree Germany is prepared now
for well-qualified people can profit
from top people from different European
countries and this is what already works
but you are right Germany isn't prepared
from the other sort of migration we
still have people who come to look for
as a simple job are not so well
qualified and Germany doesn't have the
system to integrate into the market to
help to first get language skills and
perhaps better qualification and this is
what is already well developed in
northern European countries and in my
opinion it's something Germany could
learn from this countries from this
experience so Alan Posner not everyone
is welcome only those with university
degree is
that the case yeah yeah I think it's I
think it's fair to say but that's par
for the course I mean it's not very much
better in Germany than in other places
but also not worse if you I mean
Britain you if you see the votes for the
UK but in our selection these are also
votes against immigration and against
immigration even from Europe if you look
at Denmark where you where you teach an
anti-immigration party comes in first if
you look at Finn and if you look at
Sweden you know so and I don't even want
to think what it would be like in Poland
for instance if you had the number of
immigrants shall we say from Turkey that
we have and other Eastern European
countries so yes we have a lot to do we
have a lot to learn from best practice
but quite frankly Germany is made I mean
just 20 years ago it said Germany is not
a country of immigration Deutschland is
kind of an wrong slant and now the party
which said that the CDU is for
immigration it was really bland who said
does boat as for the boat is full and
that was 40 years ago or 50 and now look
at us so credit where credit is due
we've done a lot and aside from the
economic aspects can you think of other
aspects other reasons why immigrants are
choosing to come to Germany perhaps a
new more positive image well I think
we've cleaned up our act a lot we have
really done a lot there's been stuff
like the conference on on Islam to
integrate Islamic to try and integrate
people who are Muslims we've done a lot
in schools - - to get people to learn we
we do try to you know I my wife is a
teacher in Berlin wedding which is an
immigrant she in her class most of the
people are Turkish and and you know they
are actually speaking German now much
better than they did 10 years ago so it
was cos it's very interesting drama nerd
yes great opportunities it's nothing in
comparison to United States of course
United States you have all the
possibilities at the universities you
can do anything you only want to you
only have to want it yes and you have
all possibilities but even yes in German
has changed a lot and for scholars an
attractive place universities
an active place and libraries and
archive so far well qualified people
German is interesting place it's also a
country where you have nothing to fear I
mean the German democracy is functioning
very well look at your Chancellor in
here Angela Merkel she's very laid-back
she's very cool you might or might not
agree with her politics that's something
else but she doesn't frighten anybody
anymore marine lepen frightens me and a
lot of people yeah I mean it's a country
where democracy works the German I've
just been on holiday in Morocco and it
was very interesting because they say oh
you know German car is it's a dream of
every everybody and they say the germs
yeah they're nice they're nice they're
boring there be square but they are nice
they are there you know they they don't
frighten any more any longer yeah and I
mean I'm I go to Israel regularly
because I have relatives there in Israel
you say I come from Berlin I mean used
to be 20 years ago some people would
sort of go back like this which you can
understand but now it's a oh well in its
either I was there last month or its I'm
going there next month you know so and
Berlin is generating this huge sort of
surge of sympathies you know that the
cultural center of Europe French Jews
buy flats in Tel Aviv and Jerusalem
apparently the the price of the of the
property has rised
because the French Jews want to have a
food somewhere else and possibly in
Israel to be able to go out if it gets
worse whereas Israelis are buying a
property in Berlin some people point
towards the World Cup 2006 as that
marked somewhat of the beginning of an
image of a more positive and friendly
Germany do you think that would be
overstating the factor of sports or do
you think it really had something to do
with Germany's image outside being much
more positive let me suppose it has to
do with Dominus image and after 2004 and
July 2006 it became strong Germany
started to be presented as a very
tolerant
- open-minded culture with a lot of
possibilities since when I compare the
media reports in Central European
countries I can notice it has changed a
lot and before 2004 Domino was presented
in completely different way as a country
we are not so much welcomed and perhaps
you could change your mind and to
migrate to other countries and it's very
interesting because before 2004 must
qualified pores and check spectryx not
so much they don't show like migration
but pores they went to create pregnant
in lunch and to Germany arrived are not
so well qualified Polish people and now
has changed the most qualified Polish
people they don't know to create
Brittany Island but to dominate and this
is very interesting trend and allan
poe's that you already mentioned the
experience you encounter when you travel
to Israel for instance this also this
experiences is it also shown when you
travel within Europe for instance I just
came back from Greece and it's
interesting I mean you you know in a
shop and they they ask you where you
come from and try to try to stammer
Greek it doesn't work and you say
Germany you know two out of three people
will just slightly drawback because they
view Germany and mrs. marker as the
country which is forcing austerity on
them and so I didn't experience any sort
of real sort of anger but a certain
coolness so I imagine and I'm going to
Portugal in the summer I'm gonna be
interested how that happens I imagine
there is this you know there is that
that we are seen as the juggernaut you
know just putting a dick tart on the
rest of Europe and fact is there's also
some truth to that so yeah there's that
ambivalence there is that ambivalence
also being felt in France very much so
very much so I mean the French are very
special they have a very special
relationship to Germany because they
admire what the Germans have done I'm
it's the only country which is doing
well economically guitar coda
the
Chancellor is a is a is a hero in France
because he's reformed the economy and
our political can only dream of it I
mean they haven't done anything that's
why they've had so much so bad results
at the European elections so there is
this side of great admiration and we
want to copy them we want to do as they
do on the other hand there's a lot of
envy as well you know why have they
managed and we haven't and and you have
top very very prominent French
politicians who suddenly compared Angela
Merkel with Bismarck which is which is
absurd so you know you there's a lot of
a psychology in it as well and things
which come up again which are funny
which are completely irrational and very
unfair but it's a very ambivalent
relationship and the image of Germany is
even very popular in Poland obviously a
country that has also had some
historical grievances here oh yes of
course and it's very positive image now
and it has changed a lot when we
compared the situation with the
situation after the Second World War
when Germany was the first enemy but
later on in the night is changed into
Russia became the biggest enemy and
Germany started to be a best friend a
Polish French button we have to say that
poles are very rational people and yes
this is the reason why yes this picture
and presentation of drama need change
because of first of all of the economic
development this is what Polish people
impressed this is what they copied
imported Poland on the other hand turn
from Spain as well in that time after
before the financial crisis and after
transition process in Spain so in Poland
take Coppedge this transformation from
totalitarian into democratic system in
Spain and well developed
economy in Germany and this is the most
important polish partner Germany the
most important because of course it's
neither labor country because Germany
supports polenta large politically and
economically but another issue that I
would like to mention what still doesn't
work in the German immigration system in
language skills German language it's
very interesting when I compare with
other countries in in Germany it's like
home you have to speak German from the
beginning to give your best to can show
that you always well qualified to can
show you are from the best immigrants
because it's like German people in they
express and they see too much behind the
language skill it's different in the
northern countries when you arrive there
you have to speak English but the most
important is what you are saying what
you are thinking and what you can give
from yourself yes language doesn't
really play any role and after that
after you have arrived there you have to
learn this language but not from it's
not the most important point what you
would you agree no I wanted to go back
to this beautiful relationship between
Poland and Germany cos and this
rationale poles well the rationale poles
if I remember not so long ago have
compared Angela Merkel with Hitler and
they were massive and very very
aggressive press campaigns against
Germany but you are I'm not quite sure
so it's so so relaxed between these two
countries and I think I don't think that
the I mean I think the the pose that's
why I think I understand that are very
much like the French you know when you
are insecure and the French are very
insecure it's a French problem it's not
the German from the French are very
insecure at the moment and then you
attack the Germans it's always very
comfortable and very easy and it works
because the Germans they
they would treat they don't attack back
which is good I admire Angela Merkel I
don't know how she does it because she
says oh you know when it's freedom of
speech if they want to compare with
Hitler if they want to compare me with
be smart let's do it let them do it and
she's extremely strong and that's the
best attitude allan poe's i do you think
that this ambivalence that we've talked
on today's show about germany being a
very popular country but at the same
time it's also being seen as imposing on
the european scene anyway and when that
happens the german chancellor is being
compared to very ugly individuals from
the german past what do you make of
these chief shots I mean at the end of
the day what do they reveal not so much
about Germany but their neighbors
well like Pascal said it's its
insecurities and it's easy you know to
to bash Germany because of what Germany
did Germany can't escape its past there
is that I mean we occupied France we
occupied Poland we used Poland as
killing fields and so on I mean it's
just terrible and so and Greece and so
on
so you do that you have to expect that
people are gonna use you then and not
gonna let you forget and that's you know
that's fair enough I don't hold it
against them I think one thing I have to
say is one reason why the poles like the
Germans are present more than the French
too is that they are not in the euro if
you were in the euro and Germany was
dictating to you you know cut this
budget slashed that budget you know you
would be feeling quite different I think
as they do in Greece and I'm amazed
actually that the radicals didn't get
more votes in Greece while the German
past as Alan Posner said is not in
question for obvious reasons spots the
future that very much lies upon this
nation also is not a question it seems
to be rather strong democracy is healthy
in this country says Pascal you go one
of the reasons is our Constitution
post-world War two Constitution which we
just mark the 65th anniversary of and to
do so there was a very remarkable
speaker and a remarkable incident
leading up to it in the German Bundestag
let's have a quick look
Naveed karmani whose parents came here
from Iran used the occasion to raise
some difficult issues about German
immigration he said while Germany had
become a much more open society it could
do more to accept people from other
countries especially asylum seekers
Germany doesn't have to accommodate all
who are weary and burdened in this world
but it has enough resources to protect
the victims of political persecution
rather than shifting responsibility onto
so-called third States
besides legislative changes karmani said
Germany needs a change of attitude this
country he said should be proud that
people want to come here this is a good
Germany the best that we know rather
than closing up it can be proud that
it's become so attractive but he also
pointed out that those who came to this
country in search of opportunity need to
make an effort on the other hand perhaps
immigrants have at times fail to make
sufficiently clear just how much they
value the freedom that they share in
both in its praise and its criticism
Kimani speech was food for thought Alan
Posner before we get to the content of
the speech how remarkable was it that
such a momentous speech was giving given
by somebody of Persian descent a Muslim
if you will at the German Bundestag does
it show that Germany is finally coming
to terms with its own diversity yes I
think it does and it happened in a week
we're at the where president Gauck as I
said who didn't speak in interesting
enough in the Parliament for the 65th
anniversary of the Constitution where he
however said that he wanted a new German
we of diversity and remember his
predecessor was criticized and Christian
more of his predecessors as president
was criticized for saying that Islam
belongs to Germany and now a Muslim is
speaking on the German constitution to
the German Bundestag
it is quite a remarkable thing
and you know I'd be the first to say it
we have a lot to do and that there you
know and there's tons of prejudice to be
to be pushed aside but this really was
quite something
Aegina so close indeed a persian a
german of persian descent is being asked
to give this momentous speech on the eve
of the 65th anniversary of the german
constitution a lot of people have been
saying Germany's not really comfortable
with its own diversity it's not
embracing its diversity and if we look
at the numbers 20% of all Germans have a
so-called migrant backgrounds do you
think we're entering a new phase here oh
yes of course
sure and this is what we thought before
that in comparison we always have to
compare how the situation has changed
because without a comparison it's it's
difficult to give a statement and to say
what our development chest escort Obert
but in comparison yes I'm of the opinion
that Germany has become a much more
tolerant open-minded and is able to not
only to accept diversity but to use this
diversity in a positive way to profit
from this diversity and to copy the best
copy the best says Cartagena stock Loza
basically when we compare the situation
Germany to France
obviously France also has a very large
migrant community and we've seen some
unfortunate events in the bond years
with cars being burned and riots and so
on so forth we haven't seen this sort of
outbreak here in Germany thankfully yet
what does Germany do better than France
well I think there are many first of all
there are many many reasons first of all
the immigration in France is these are
the old French colonies and if you take
Algeria for example it's a very very
complicated difficult aggressive history
we have in common I mean the the the the
liberation the accession through
independence led to war and these are
things which haven't been worked out I
mean it's so these things so flower
in when the situation becomes difficult
then in Germany you don't have this huge
ball use these talents outside the
cities where all the immigrants ghettos
were all the immigrants live together
which are of course explosive and I
think that the French society at the
moment is more racist than the German
society I mean it is really because we
feel insecure because of the I mean not
not only economically but also in our
identity we were and we still think a
lot of politician you hear the speeches
of politician they still think France is
you know a leading country in the world
but we're a tiny little country
somewhere in Europe we haven't got any
power anymore and that's very very
difficult for the French to accept and
then you retract in this sort of
nationalistic fear and it's very
difficult for for immigration opposed I
of course it would also be dishonest not
to mention that a fraction of the German
Bundestag off the parliamentarians from
the Christian Democrats walked out and
protest because they felt not with care
money was not a suitable speaker or
rather also the content and which I want
to get to namely that he says Germany
must do more should do more Germany up
until now has taken in 10,000 refugees
from Syria for instance you've already
mentioned Lampedusa and and so on so
forth do you think with this newly
gained popularity and respect across the
globe comes the new responsibility as
well do you think care money is right
when he says Germany is not doing enough
well my heart says he's right you can't
you know see the pictures of immigrants
landing and boats in Nampa do sir and
not feel that we have to do more to help
the to help these asylum seekers and
immigrants from terrible parts of the
world and also to help Italy or Greece
other countries whose economies are in a
bad shape and have to deal with this
situation or Lebanon which has huge
influx of refugees from Syria and which
is a country which hardly exists so you
know from a moral point of view I think
he's absolutely right there there is it
on the other hand if you are are
política if you think in that respect
one reason
why for instance Sarkozy was so
successful against Madame Lipan was
because he took a hard line in
immigration and sort of said is going to
go in there with the cash and clean out
you know and this was ugly but it kept
people away from the pen and there's a
certain rationale for saying that we
need the right-wing Christian Democrats
to be a bit tougher on immigration in
order to keep the you know fascist and
and external phobic elements down so
with my heart I'm with him with my brain
I'm thinking we have to be careful here
well we'll see if we can reconcile the
heart and brain of Alain Posner before
the end of the show but the cattiness no
closer indeed the question always comes
up about German Germany's responsibility
especially in times where it's doing
good in economic terms and so and so
forth but that's bad news for German
politicians who have both the German
president Gauck as well as the German
Foreign Minister Steinmeier who in the
past few months have said yes we are
willing to do our share is bad news
because the poll just recently published
by the Kerber foundation is saying
Germans don't want that quite on the
contrary Germans want the the country to
stay out of international conflicts how
do you solve this dilemma of course it's
the amount majority of German population
says we don't want to have the whole
possibility for all political and
economic problems in Europe and outside
Europe we have to share our
responsibility but very in spoken
important aspect we have inter mentioned
until now the reason why Germany has
become so open-minded and tolerant is
the question of nationalism a question
of identity and it's completely
different in Germany than in other
European countries
above all France or Baltic countries or
Poland we have a very so give a specific
example one example where for my
students I have first students from more
than 30 countries in my classes and I
always try to deconstruct nationalism
national States and to think about about
in read
identities in common undated identities
and it's so obvious for my German
students they understand it and they say
we don't feel German what we don't
really we feel European or we feel from
beau Brandenburg Saxony from Berlin so
they understand me but my friends
students or from Estonia what I think
but above all and how should we why
should we the Constructors because and
this is very important I think this
German in German not German identity if
German European and entity and anti
nationalistic and day today could be
model you know why the Germans wanted to
be European I mean it had a function
here because they didn't have to be
German they just get on my nerves
because what's so wrong about being
German being French you know you can be
European - but it wasn't ears that's
identity for the German long time and
anyone they wanted to be you know once
you get very very far away from their
German then they would say they are very
pure there are citizens of the world
which is what is the season of the world
I mean it is so I think it's much it I
would prefer it when the drum said which
they did since the last VM we're quite
glad to be Germany it's ok now you know
especially the young generation to be
relaxed about it and then to be European
but this sort of not wanting to be
German is very suspect for me I agree I
agree totally it's it's it's escape
mechanism and you have to reconcile well
as Pascal said you have to reconcile
being British being polish and being
European and being German and in my case
have a mixed identity I mean I'm my
father my parents are British my family
comes from Germany so I've got two
passports but I am a British paid for it
and I'm a German patriot and I'm also a
European patriot it works you can do it
well we'll see that one when the Germany
meets Britain at the World Cup
and of course we'll see when I'm gonna
have a really hard time where I live
because I'll be the only one wife going
for England yeah but it's being set and
I want to come back to the point of
Germany embracing its own diversity
because there are some people out there
say you know on the surface that might
be true but if we look at the numbers if
we look at the polls that are being
conducted and if we look at unfortunate
events like the NSU trial for instance
and so this thing yes and no you know
it's a yes and no thing and perhaps
Pascal you want to China I think I don't
want to do some I mean the poor Germans
you know now at last they are loved from
everybody and here I come
destroy that I think if the economy
wasn't so booming here I think if the
identity was not sort of relaxing then
you would have the same Abbas my said
the question the last we said I want to
to apologize
my my country with what happened and
Sunday's is really terrible but I think
this this reflects of of xenophobia and
wanted to cut shut down and being
nationalistic and not wanting to this
would happen if this country was not so
so so successful economically I'm sure
you have that here as well and if
somebody like marine lepen somebody
respectable with who can talk with a
political I mean it's the Commission is
very very professional very professional
you don't have any any exam of phobic
potholes in their in their speeches if
you had a party like that or a person
like that I'm not quite sure I mean this
alternative a few doors and this new
party whose anti euro I mean the guy
who's leading it is
I mean he's not extremely charismatic
hal leuco he's not very charismatic if
you had somebody like Martin Lupin I'm
not sure but I am not agreeing
I'm afraid alternative for Germany can
become really dangerous with the time
because they have a lot of intellect
towards behind and in the party and this
is always the most dangerous development
well-qualified intellectual people with
such nationalistic see Oh God I mean
it's complicated we don't know we don't
know I mean it's a you know the
formation alexander phobic anti-semitic
party and you can say that it's true we
are glad that we in germany haven't had
the same results at the EU polls but we
started this show with the question
whether germany is a land of
opportunities and i want to spend the
remainder of the time on the show on
that because if we look at the statistic
figures put forth by the OECD and the UN
they say they still say that social
mobility and economic prosperity in the
future is still very closely linked to
one's socio-economic and ethnic
background and you mentioned your wife
who's a schoolteacher what what must
Germany do better here well Katrina's
put put it I mean it's not only language
skills it's skills you have to have a
change of mindset because let's face it
Germany was also very lucky in its
immigrants we have a Turkish emigrate
large Turkish immigration population not
from the market up like in like in
France and these are very hard working
people who although they weren't allowed
to take jobs then you know they took
over the the you know they they became
tailors they became the you know they
had fruit stalls in the market and so on
they host TV Oh Stephen you know I mean
they really and I'm not saying this to
compliment you they are really
hard-working people and they've shown
that they grasp the opportunities they
have we have to give them more
opportunities I'm sure it's in the case
of freeing up your Orca see to give
people chances
and in schools very definitely the
mindset of teachers has to change not
saying you know so who are you but what
can you do and and and this is in a deed
not tied to language because someone can
be very intelligent stumble over
language give them an opportunity that
is changing but it's training too slowly
I agree there because you know what
about the new immigrants we've talked
about those who've been here for perhaps
a 30 40 years about their chances to
move up the economic social ladder and
their offspring what about the ones that
say I'm gonna come to Germany now is
that a land of opportunities
oh yes of course it's a land of
opportunities and this is why many of
them decide to stay for longer or
forever
and many Poles they arrive and they
would like to find a good job even it's
worse than in Poland a lot of
well-qualified Polish people arrive and
take a job that it worse than their job
in Poland because it brings more money
and this is why they say ok this will be
only for one year or perhaps fears and
after they they decide to stay for
longer because sir yes they have started
to like this country and because they
have started to see a lot of
possibilities opportunities a lot of
possibilities a lot of opportunities
Pascal you came to Germany obviously and
you States what made you stay well
that's four words a very nice place to
live Berlin no I wouldn't say I would
live in Dusseldorf or in streetcar but
pardon definite is of course we have
viewers in the solutions of care as well
there they did not they did not hear
that part but would you also subscribe
to the fact that Germany is a land of
opportunities yes absolutely absolutely
I mean so it's a very solid democracy
it's a place where you don't have to
fear anything it's a place where you
have a social nest I mean you can't
nothing can happen you can go to the
doctor you can you can you have
unemployment money if you if you are on
earth and and it's a place where there's
work which economically booms what you
want more
Germany is booming I think that's become
very clear on to ratio and hopefully
we'll continue to do so for some
to come Germany the second most popular
immigration country in the world let's
see how that will play out we of course
on DW will continue to follow this story
I want to thank my guests for a very
spirited discussion one where we examine
Germany from bottom to top and I think
came out with a lot of results thank you
out there for tuning in and looking
forward to seeing you again next week
for a new edition of quadriga